and we'll see what kyle hart has in
store today hope he can give them some
length today and that's the second
straight walk and the phillies have him
loaded very hot hitter here obviously
gosling at 429
then when he fights off and hits toward
right field it's in for a base hit one
run is in that's all mccutcheon scores
hoskins to third harper to second rbi
single for gosselin and the phillies
take a one-nothing lead and now
and he lines that one out towards center
field it's not deep bradley's got it
he'll make the catch here comes hoskins
the throw to the plate he is out but i
thought he got under that
yeah they're gonna look at it i thought
he slid under the tag john it was just
high up on the leg yeah he's in oh yeah
safe at home so a sac fly for d.d
gregorius philly's leading two nothing
jake arietta one and two 402 era 15.2
innings pitch 17 hits 14 k's three balls
and two strikes verdugo with the
nine-game hitting streak coming in the
pitch strike called got him
and now raphael differs
play by real muto the throw to first
base and he is out at first base pilar
when slips slide it all over jt making
the first pick off by a catcher
look easy
oh it's the sixth pick off overall for
the phillies goliath took ball four in
the first inning
that one tagged head of the wall rising
up and that ball is off the green
pillar digging into second a little bit
of a bobble out there by garlic
and pilar is aboard with a double with
two now raffy with a pair of home runs
stroke to center field backing up
kingery turning around that ball is gone
they crushed it to center field
and he has tied the game off of arietta
that was a shot
that is the old divers and what a shot
that was
[Applause]
up in the strike zone think about where
his hits have been you know the opposite
field last night a ground ball up the
middle and now the straight away center
field for the long ball
here's bogart
out to right field pretty deep harper's
going back toward the fence reaches up
and he makes the grab
stayed with that one red sox dead even
here with the phillies mitch moreland is
on he'll take the walk vasquez bounced
into a double play hit a bullet at the
second baseman he loops this one into
right field to base hit this will get
moral into third rolling along the foul
line picked up by harper
and runners are at first and third with
nobody out a little player first and
third for jackie bradley
jackie bradley stings that one on his
horse kingery he'll run it down on the
warning track mitch moreland can tag up
he races in to score and the red sox
have the lead for the first time three
to two
for dugo
stings that one the other way that's
headed for the wall he slices it right
off the monster
burdugo with a 10-game hitting streak as
he goes sliding in
pilar gets in at 303 with two home runs
poked on the ground of the first baseman
hoskins with a bobble and now aaron flip
off the glove of arietta here's the play
at the plate that one's thrown away
radugo comes diving in and the red sox
lead it four to two i don't know what
kind of flip that was arietta scoops it
throws he throws it away
all kind of bad throws going on weber
coming out of the pen third red sox
pitcher today gosselin has singled in a
run it was in the first inning
in there four strike three and again got
something extra on that corner
so the man out and a runner at third
hoskins will be the batter oh
round ball and he'll send a runner home
oh my goodness that one's thrown away
talk about air mail
run comes in
to make it 4-3 he's got no play at home
i don't know why he would look that way
and then he had to rush into first base
barnes coming on and a tying run at
second base for the phillies and bryce
harper the batter
swing and a miss struck him out boy that
was pretty filthy
real muto is 0-4-2 with a walk
swung on and misty put him away matt
barnes with a big big effort
back to back hayes
and deborah's seemingly locked in here
with an opportunity to give the red sox
a little bit of a cushion
that one's driven that's going to be off
the wall
that'll bring in another run rodul will
score diving into second throw gets away
and he's got himself another extra base
hit
and a three-hit game for the second day
in a row warriors with a lead at first
and the count runs full de bone
and a ground ball nice snatch there by
lynn
at second got him onto first and got him
so the red sox with men on the corners
nobody out and jackie bradley eyeing his
second rbi on the day
jackie with a high fly ball in the right
center field driven deep kingery back
it's over his head into the triangle
mitch moreland is in to score
vasquez trots into third and it's an rbi
double
[Music]
jackie bradley jr delivers again damn
brand new workman first time we've seen
him in five days here's
mccutcheon i fly ball that should do it
for dugo and bradley jackie makes the
catch and the red sox win it the sweet
taste of victory
red sox in the win column they knock off
the phillies and split this series 6-3
the final score